Hi Bill.
My name is Sam.
My question for you is why are we trying to
live on Mars and re-create Earth there by
making an atmosphere and soil and water we
can drink and such?
Why can't we take those ideas, that motivation
and direct it at our own planet that we clearly
need the help with?
Why is it easier to start fresh on another
planet than to get people talking about our
own?
Sam.
Sam, you are my man.
Sam, you're thinking as I do.
I meet a lot of people.
I am the CEO of The Planetary Society.
We advanced space science and exploration.
I encourage you to join.
And as I say about The Planetary Society,
we are not crazy.
You meet a lot of people.
I meet a lot of people who want to go to Mars
and make it like Earth, just as the very idea
that you're questioning.
And I think people, first of all, just don't
grasp the scale of it.
It's a planet.
It's a whole planet.
It's not a wetland that you can reclaim and
build a parking garage on top of, it's a whole
planet.
Furthermore, this planet where you and I are
from is perfectly suited to us.
We, our ancestors and their ancestors and
so on grew up here tuned to these environments,
to these climates that we have here on earth.
And so people want to go to Mars in the spirit
of adventure.
Now, as you may infer from my accent I'm from
the United States and a lot of my ancestors
came here from Denmark and Europe and they
set up shop in what the colony of Massachusetts
and then they went all the way across North
America through Wyoming, the state of Wyoming
and now to the West Coast to Washington state
and California.
And they did that in this great tradition
of a pioneering spirit is keep going, keep
expanding, keep spreading out and humankind
has done that.
Everybody is from Africa.
Our ancestors are all from the continent of
Africa and we spread all over the world.
Spread to Australia across an open ocean.
The Polynesians in canoes were like we're
spreading out man.
We're going.
So people think well let's spread out and
go to Mars.
It's a whole other thing to go to Mars.
I tell people this all the time.
There's hardly any water.
There's a little bit.
There is nothing to eat.
There is no air.
There's no air.
We can build a bubble and cook the Martian
rocks and get the oxygen out of it.
Okay, it's just not so easy.
Just as you asked Sam why don't we do that
here on earth or use that same technology
here on earth?
And this is part of my little mission as a
human, not CEO of The Planetary Society is
reminding everybody that we've got to take
care of the earth in order for us all to live
here.
There's 7.3 billion people as we're recording
right now.
By 2050 there will be nine maybe even 10 billion
people by the middle of this century.
And they're all going to want to eat something
and drink something, water and wash and a
carry on and that's going to require us to
take much better care of our own planet.
Now, with that said, I like to remind everybody
also, although you don't want to go to Mars
and have a permanent settlement there, a colony,
you do want to have a base there just as humankind
has a base in the Antarctic where scientists
go and study the Antarctic, learn about the
environment, learn about our planet, learn
about ice and the Earth's history and the
climate today and the greenhouse gases and
the effect of industrial emissions and so
on, all these discoveries are made in Antarctica.
If we were to discover evidence of life on
Mars, something that was once alive there
the equivalent of what geologists call stromatolite,
fossilized bacteria that have turned to stone,
it would be astounding if we found something
still alive there.
There are these recurring slope lineae, which
is geology expression for what look like rivulets,
look like little rivers.
They may be just rock falls like turned over
gravel that has a slightly different color
than the surrounding rock, but everybody thinks
right now that it's water.
Everybody's pretty sure – by everybody we're
talking about people at the National Aeronautics
and Space Station NASA and the European Space
Agency ESA, JAXA Japanese Aerospace Exploration,
Roscosmos.
Everybody believes that if there's recurring
flows of water every Martian summer there
must be some subterranean, some under sand/ice
melts.
And if you have liquid water anywhere on earth
there's something alive.
Everywhere there's liquid water there's something
alive.
If there's something alive on Mars, and we
could prove it, show it to ourselves with
our spacecraft or with human explorers walking
around, it would probably change the world.
It would be equivalent to the discoveries
that Copernicus made that the earth goes around
– all the planets go around the sun, not
the other way around.
Or Galileo, we're not the only body out in
the cosmos.
We've got the moon.
In fact to Jupiter has its own moons and these
other discoveries that were so profound.
If we were to find life on another world it
would change this one.
And there's one more element that we at The
Planetary Society celebrate, these discoveries,
this discovery of life on Mars or on the moon
of Jupiter that has twice as much seawater
as the earth.
It's called Europa.
You can see it with binoculars at night.
If we make this discovery of life, it would
not have been done by an individual, by Galileo
or Copernicus or Irene Curie, it would be
done by a society who invested its intellect
and treasure in this quest let's go see what's
out there.
Let's learn more about ourselves, our past
and we all want to know whether or not we're
alone in the universe.
So if we look on these two worlds, the earth
and mars and find a life on both of them,
that would suggest that life is very common
in the cosmos.
And this would affect the way each and everyone
of us feels about what it means to be a living
thing in the cosmos; what it means to have
this place in space.
That's a great question.
Carry-on!